Western culture has a long history of
emotional anxiety by which I mean
anxiety about emotions a thinkers from
the Classical period to the modern have
pitted emotion against reason as
opposing forces vying for the minds
control an emotional person was seen as
weak giving in to the path of least
resistance to base desires ruled by
capricious feelings fear is the path to
the dark side the strong on the other
hand would rule their emotions with
reason everyone feels pressure winners
don't let it show
Disney personified the struggle and
assur eight-minute cartoon from 1943
called aptly reason and emotion within
the mind of each of us these two wage a
ceaseless battle from mastering the
short is a lightly disguised propaganda
piece heartening Americans against fear
tactics used by the Axis powers in World
War two but it was nonetheless a point
of reference for the Pixar team led by
director Pete docter responsible for the
film inside out doctors film is a far
more nuanced take on the inner workings
of the mind appropriate for a
post-freudian post Cultural Revolution
age when were encouraged ostensibly at
least to embrace emotions rather than
urged to master them the film tells the
story of the 11-year old Riley as she
navigates a move across the country and
more centrally how five emotions joy the
leader sadness fear disgust and anger
balance the control of her mind from a
mission control like headquarters in
this model each day consists of discrete
moments colored by one of the five
emotions which are sent during sleep to
a vast archive of long-term memories
very rarely an experience is so
formative that it creates a core memory
which goes on to form the basis of
Riley's personality imagined as theme
park islands when joy and sadness are
accidentally ejected from head
the film chronicles their cathartic
journey through several other mental
regions including Imaginationland a
dream production company that looks like
the Paramount lot abstract thought and a
subconscious jail the catharsis comes
when joy realizes that sadness is not
only useful but essential perhaps even
more essential than she is - Riley's
harmonious mental functioning and
overall happiness the film itself and
its message to embrace sadness to feel
what needs feeling is surely a token of
progress against our long-standing
emotional anxiety but is this model of
the mind and its emotions an accurate
one inside out basis its theory of
emotions in large part on the work of
Paul Ekman and influential scientists in
the psychology of emotion Eckman posits
that there are seven basic emotions with
Universal facial signals the ones
featured in the film plus two that were
cut surprise and contempt these basic
emotions are ubiquitous the world over
Ahmed says and can be read on the faces
of anyone whether that's by an astute
listener or facial recognition software
like those Eggman has helped develop
controversially for security and
marketing mrs. Eckman and other
consultants on the film have praised
inside-out for providing a model for
kids that is engaging as well as
scientifically sound but though Ekman's
model may be the dominant one in the
psychology of emotion right now it's by
no means the only indeed the field is a
far more fractious one than the film
scientific consultants LED on inside out
seems to suggest that a child's
experiences will be defined by whichever
emotion is at the helm what's more that
overall personality determined by
colored core memories has an emotional
driver this model stands opposite to the
key insights of psychoanalysis for
example which hold that emotions can be
transferred transformed or distorted
expressions of unconscious ideas and
repressed experiences in other words
feelings of sadness or joy or fear are
free
quickly far removed from their causes
understanding them as specific entities
is troublesome because they're often not
what they seem to be which is to say
that understanding emotion as the driver
and not the expression of ideas and
experience may ignore underlying causes
indeed the idea that emotions or
memories can be separate or discrete in
any way is a dubious one the film itself
begins to challenge this at the end when
the control panel in headquarters is
expanded to fit all the emotions and
when the memory orbs start to reflect
mixed experience but a sense that
experience can be quantified pervades
the film and like anything that may
reflect more about our culture at the
moment than the science itself for joy
and sadness the scariest place in the
film isn't the subconscious prison that
houses Riley's worst fears but a giant
pit in the center of Riley's mind where
memories are forgotten forever without
any hope of recall an increasingly
data-driven culture where more data
equals more truth the greatest anxiety
of all is the loss of information and
the headquarters of Riley's mind does
feel a bit managerial with its control
panel and user manuals and Riley a bit
like an automaton controlled by a highly
sophisticated technocratic operation the
decision-making process is a bit wonky
too since the latest neuroscience tells
us that the frontal lobe in acts kind of
executive function that mediates between
the emotions in the limbic system and
higher cognitive functions like
reflection and critical thinking
obviously not always in favour of the
latter maybe at this point you're saying
the same thing as the voice in my own
it's a kids movie it's a comedy that's
very true and the director Pete docter
has never held this film up as an
academic or therapeutic tool he admits
the need for poetic and comedic license
adding an executive function like the
kind I just mentioned for example would
no doubt make the film too complex as
with any number of other things like the
two basic emotions he left out or any
other emotion I don't think his dramatic
instincts can be questioned here under
the premises of the emotional model that
inside out presents the narrative
unfolds with
grace subtlety and intense poignancy
I'll leave the formal critique to
someone else but there is no doubt that
this is masterful filmmaking I had the
tears to prove it but it does raise
questions about the effect of popular
models of the mind
Pixar tells stories so mythic and
archetypal and so well that it's all but
impossible not to internalize some of
their elements especially for kids if
the result is that children learn
earlier and better why it's important to
accept and expect sadness then I think
it's unquestionably a good thing but
sadness and joy and fear and disgust and
anger are not discrete things or
self-contained or even fully internal
neither our personality traits or for
that matter personalities any model of
emotion is going to reflect a split
between biology and culture between
neuroscience and theoretical
psychoanalysis don't let anyone tell you
that that debate has been decided one
way or the other there are as many
emotional theories as there are
emotional psychologists what's
interesting and ironic about inside out
is that Riley may come off as a bit
robotic but a more complex and complete
framework for the inner workings of the
mind can be found in joy herself a
character who questions and reflects who
turns inward not to another smaller
headquarters but a cauldron of
indistinct compounds of feeling
influenced by chemistry situation and
other people inside out may not be
perfectly accurate but the film inspires
something more important than that
something that doesn't require
scientific exactness
emotional intelligence it is a sunny day
us right now hi everybody thanks for
watching
I love Pixar generally but I love this
movie just because it gives you so much
to dig into and explore and I had a lot
of fun making this and putting this
together
if you think that the nerd writer and
what I'm doing here is something that
you're not seeing elsewhere on on
YouTube you can pledge a little to my
channel by clicking here and going to my
patreon it's what funds this project and
helps me improve the quality there's so
much more I want to do this more series
that I'm going to be introducing soon
and the funding is what makes it
possible I mean that that's the unique
relationship between you and me there's
nothing in between us
and what you give me the money you give
me helps me to make this project better
and more in-depth and I hope that you
trust that I will do that by you know by
the quality of the content that I've
made so far so thank you so much again
for watching and I'll see you guys next
Wednesday